bonjour Bruno Millien je suis député de
la 9e circonscription des Yvelines et
avec mon collègue Gérard le seul nous
avons fait un rapport sur les ZF les
zones affaiblissement mobilité avec tous
les freins à la mise en place de ces
ETFE et toutes les contraintes que ça
suppose pour les habitants pour les
particuliers comme pour les
professionnels et mon boulot maintenant
c'est d'aller en circonscription pour
expliquer ça à nos administrés à nos
concitoyens et leur dire qu'on a des
solutions alternatives et qu'il faut
absolument les mettre en place parce que
c'est une question de santé publique
le sujet est brûlant voire explosif il
va toucher des millions de Français à
peine installés les aidefe suscitent
colères et inquiétudes
les ZFE ce sont les zones à faible
émission de mobilité
petit à petit les véhicules les plus
polluants ne pourront plus y circuler
[Musique]
l'objectif réduire les émissions de
polluants et améliorer la qualité de
l'air chaque année la pollution
atmosphérique du 48 000 Français
11 métropoles ont déjà mis en place une
ZFE et toutes les agglomérations de plus
de 150 000 habitants vont devoir le
faire d'ici 2025
les habitants de Mézières à 55 km de
Paris dans la circonscription du député
doivent déjà composer avec la ZF
parisienne
ici beaucoup s'y rendre tous les jours
en voiture
Bruno millienne compte sur la pédagogie
pour la faire accepter
dans ces zones périphériques le sujet
est sensible c'est une centaine de
kilomètres tous les jours entre ici
là-bas les déplacements clientèle je
vais de l'autre côté Paris enfin bon
voilà je suis pleinement concernée on en
arrive même à faire du covoiturage mais
du coup c'est moi qui rapatrie tout le
monde je vais prendre tous ici et on va
ensemble travailler aujourd'hui si tu
dois changer de véhicule tu passerais à
l'électrique ou à l'hybride électrique
hors de question pourquoi je suis
parfois amené à faire des antennes de
kilomètres
et sincèrement je me vois pas
habituellement en appartement déjà j'ai
pas de prise donc tout ce qui est
électrique c'est impossible et avec nos
revenus malheureusement on peut pas se
permettre d'aller vers des véhicules
vous ferez quoi malheureusement on va on
aura pas le choix comme tout le monde de
trouver notre alternative
si j'ai pas le choix bah soit je
démissionnerai soit transport en commun
mes amis c'est la même chose on en parle
parce qu'en fait ils disent on va
peut-être devoir quitter démissionner
parce qu'on pourra pas faire autrement
quand on a fait cette mission on a bien
on a bien eu conscience de tous les
freins qu'il y a et de l'explosion
sociale que ça pouvait être maintenant
le boulot qu'on a fait c'est d'arriver à
trouver à tout le monde une alternative
à la voiture au niveau des transports
c'est compliqué moi par exemple j'ai pas
de bus pas de train je suis obligé de
faire au moins une demi heure de voiture
pour accéder au train une heure et demie
à 2h de train
en voiture pour aller chez moi j'ai 80
km je mets une heure en ayant les
bouchons je comprends bien là le pour le
coup les transports en commun c'est pas
la solution on sait qu'on a un vrai
problème de transport en commun si
demain on a des locations à des tarifs
relativement à la fois sur le
l'électrique électrique c'est pas la
solution j'ai bien entendu mais au moins
sur l'hybride est-ce que ça c'est des
solutions que vous pourriez prendre si
loyer est acceptable oui on pourrait
réfléchir tout le monde est conscient
que le reste à charge encore trop
importante et tout ça c'est à l'étude au
ministère et je pense que ça va se faire
assez rapidement de manière à accélérer
le mouvement
à Paris les vignettes critères 4 et 5
sont déjà interdites en 2030 seuls les
critères 1 et les véhicules électriques
pourront circuler
il faut donc développer les alternatives
au tout voiture
ici la solution c'est le train et le
futur RER mais pour cela encore faut-il
adapter la gare
ça sera essentiel à partir du moment où
laser des feux à Paris sera contrôlé et
que les gens auront du mal à avoir
comment ils peuvent comment ils peuvent
circuler comment ils peuvent se rendre à
Paris sans sans prendre leur voiture
pour ceux qui continuent à apprendre
donc là effectivement c'est un enjeu
important
l'échéance c'est 2024 quand les
premières contraventions vont tomber le
député veut faire de cette gare des
peaux de Mézières un modèle un pôle
multimodal qui regroupe tous les modes
de transport
l'idée c'est que les automobilistes
laissent ici leur voiture pour prendre
le train
le RER ou le bus express pour Paris
les élus ont un ambitieux projet
s
à peu près sur cet endroit là tu vas
avoir un bâtiment où il y aura du
logement et le la brasserie sera au
rez-de-chaussée et tout le parking que
tu as là-bas ça a réservé au pôle des
changements multimodal avec un parking
silo de 650 places d'accord c'est un
parking en hauteur à étage à étage qui
va faire à peu près je crois qu'il va
faire quatre étages
gratuit alors il sera comme il est
conventionné de France mobilité il sera
gratuit pour tous ceux qui ont passé
une interrogation les transports en
commun seront-ils suffisants pour tous
ces nouveaux voyageurs
alors les chiffres que
Île-de-France mobilité et
d'après eux ça sera suffisamment
dimensionné après
faut se méfier d'Île-de-France mobilité
maire de Mézières-sur-Seine et chacun a
ses responsabilités comment appréhender
cette montée en puissance de la ZFE de
Paris de l'agglomération parisienne pour
l'habitant je l'apprends mal maintenant
on dit bah les amis prenez de l'essence
ville critère une et puis prenez
l'électrique ou de l'hybride et ainsi de
suite pour l'habitant pour l'administrer
et on voit aujourd'hui c'est encore plus
compliqué un euro c'est un euro et je
pense qu'il va falloir qu'on accompagne
en tout cas l'État accompagne réellement
t'accompagne déjà mon ami oui mais
encore plus oui non franchement c'est
con ça va être compliqué pour la pour
l'habitant on peut arriver à trouver une
alternative à chaque citoyen même s'ils
y croient pas aujourd'hui quand on leur
dit je te promets que ça existe
le député en est persuadé
reste à convaincre les automobilistes
l'autre mission que ces données le
député c'est d'accompagner les élus
Bruno millienne a entamé un tour de
France pour les guider dans la mise en
place des EDF
ce jour-là escale au Bouscat dans
l'agglomération de Bordeaux les élus
veulent des conseils pour leur futur ZFE
qui doit voir le jour d'ici 2025
[Musique]
le député les incite à la concertation
ce qui est arrivé c'est le fait que ça
partait dans tous les sens que chacun
faisait comme il voulait sur son
territoire sans tenir compte des
territoires à côté que ce soit les
territoires limitrophes à la ZFE or vous
le savez aussi bien que moi le problème
est pas tant à l'intérieur des ETF parce
qu'en général vous avez des mobilités
alternatives c'est plus pour les gens
qui sont à l'extérieur donc au niveau
acceptation sociale et puis aussi au
niveau acceptation économique pour tout
ce qui est commerçants artisans etc ceux
qui viennent faire les marchés à
l'intérieur des adefe pour me prendre
que faut pas leur dire on va vous aider
à changer de véhicule c'est on vous
offre une alternative qui n'est pas
forcément un véhicule il faut qu'on
repense l'usage de la voiture pour un
certain nombre de gens ça va être un
changement de vie quoi même le reste à
charge de 3 ou 4000 euros pour certaines
familles c'est inabordable ça se
programme sur plusieurs années c'est des
choix de famille qui sont faits pour
pouvoir acheter à ça ou changer de mode
de déplacement l'aspect subjectif va
être extrêmement important
de liberté
le risque de colère voire d'explosion
sociale et dans tous les esprits
il y a les particuliers mais il y a
aussi les commerçants et les artisans
qui seront directement touchés pour eux
aussi l'impact financier n'est pas
négligeable
à Bordeaux un Marc et Camille tiennent
une boutique de saumon fumé et il ne
voit pas comment ils pourront changer
d'utilitaire quand la ZF va se mettre en
place
et donc bonjour
on va pas tout manger
en livraison sur Bordeaux
alors un train
en plus vous êtes dedans
et aujourd'hui on va être obligé de
changer de véhicule parce que votre
véhicule est assez ancien voilà on va
faire effectivement des aides pour le
remplacement des véhicules utilitaires
légers
ça existe déjà on va le faire plus donc
il y aura des solutions de subvention
effectivement pour changer de véhicule
comme pour les véhicules des
particuliers les mala conversion sur un
véhicule c'est 7000 euros quand même
c'est pas rien
vous pouvez le faire sur un véhicule
d'occasion prime à la conversion sur un
risque vous avez le bonus écologique
plus la prime si si vous en avez je vous
jure aujourd'hui notre véhicule ce n'est
pas dans leur budget surtout vu la
conjoncture alors le député leur propose
une autre solution il y a d'autres
alternatives que de passer à
l'électrique il y a le rétrofitage
effectivement passer électrique qui vous
coûtera moins cher que d'en prendre un
neuf et puis il y a aussi le rétrovitage
qui peut
au gaz c'est ça
bah oui mais il est bien encore celui-là
en changeant seulement le moteur
il faut arriver à faire c'est que les
aides que vous obteniez pour passer
éventuellement à l'électrique bon ou à
autre chose en tout cas moi polluant il
faut pas que ça vous coûte plus cher que
si vous échangez votre véhicule contre
un véhicule identique au diesel ce qui
est un peu infatrace c'est toutes les
aides possibles qui ne sont pas
regroupées sur un site on a demandé
quand même qu'il y a un guichet unique
qui répertorie du coup collectivité par
collectivité à la fois les aides de
l'État qui sont communes à l'ensemble de
la France mais très bien les rappeler
quand même et les aides possibles sur
des collectivités pour que chacun sache
exactement à quoi il a le droit
un constructeur automobile a déjà
identifié ce marché du rétrofit
à Flins dans sa circonscription Bruno
milliennes vient justement découvrir le
projet du groupe Renault avec une
start-up il lance le retrofit des
véhicules utilitaires
pourquoi parce que le véhicule
utilitaire d'abord c'est essentiellement
du diesel donc il va être confronté très
vite à des changements du fait de la
mise en place notamment des RFE on a
aussi cette particularité c'est que le
véhicule il est utilisé au quotidien
pour l'activité des professionnels s'ils
ont pu leur véhicule c'est difficile
pour eux de continuer et puis c'est
aussi des véhicules qui sont plus chers
à l'achat et qui seront généralement
équipés typiquement se fatiguer du coup
le rétrophique a du sens pour sur ce
rétrofit en moteur électrique dans un
premier temps vous tapez dans le mille
donc voilà c'est parfait on n'a pas
encore fixé définitivement le prix du
rétrophique du kit en lui-même mais on
sait qu'il pourrait être redescendu par
une aide nationale
le premier utilitaire est profité
sortira en janvier 2024
le constructeur a décidé d'investir dans
les nouvelles mobilités
soient piloté par les territoires et
nous en tant qu'industriel on a besoin
en fait on aurait besoin je sais pas
d'une carte quelque chose de lisible
facile compris pour notre réseau savoir
quels sont les aides dont le territoire
quelles sont les interdictions à quel
voilà et donc ça c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on est évidemment un peu en
attente pour pouvoir accompagner
vraiment ce mouvement là de déploiement
de ce défaut
des entreprises déjà non non j'avais pas
entendu donc c'est bien c'est une pierre
de plus à l'édifice
Bruno Milliane va poursuivre son tour de
France à l'écoute des besoins à la
recherche de nouvelles idées mais il va
surtout devoir faire preuve de pédagogie
et informé sur les solutions
alternatives en 2030 80% des voitures
qui circulent aujourd'hui ne pourront
plus rentrer dans les aides